And let's say in expectation, when you go forward 100 m and come back 100 m,
you are to be where you started.
So 7 will be the correct mean. Now σ‘² is more difficult. It turns out the variances still add up.
And the way to see this is if we started over here at a well-defined zero position,
and you go to over here and you have some uncertainty as to where you might be.
And then you hit the ball back over here, your uncertainty will increase. It won't decrease.
That makes 2σ² the correct answer.
So even though we substituted the plus sign by a minus sign,
the uncertainty that comes in for either of these steps over here
will add up just the way it did before.
And I have to grant you, this wasn't an easy question and I hope you got it right.
If not, think about it and perhaps do the same quiz again.
There's some deep insight here, which is for the means the arithmetic I'm giving you
always apply straight, but for the variances things are counter-intuitive.
When we add to random variables, the variances always
just add up no matter what the operation is  plus or minus.